It's typically regarded as
a best practice that you not
use the SU command.
Why?
The rule of least privilege
that we discussed earlier.
Do you really need to switch your entire
working context over to the root user
to run a single, or
even a few, commands?
What happens if you forget that
you are currently within SU?
You could potentially do some
extremely damaging operations, and
there's no safety net there
to warn you when doing so.
Now, not every user has the ability
to work as the superuser.
You have to give that user
those permissions specifically.
We'll cover that in more detail
when we start adding new users.
For now, you know how to perform
operations as the root user, and that's
all we need to start managing software
known as packages on this machine.
So let's dive into that a bit.